hey guys what's going on welcome to
another PI game tutorial video in this
video what we're gonna be talking about
is we're going to add a intro screen so
we're not just like throwing the user
right into the game and then eventually
we're going to add some buttons to the
intro screen as well so stay tuned for
that so what we're going to do is
basically right above the game loop is
where we're going to define a new
function and that's going to be game
intros so we're just going to do define
game underscore intro empty parameters
and this is going to be like a little
separate sequence basically you can
think of it as then our game loop so
game intro is just going to run one time
and then what we can do and I'll
probably show in a later video but you
can use the same sort of logic with game
intro and make something like a pause
screen or you know like a control screen
like from pause you can hit controls or
something like that you know you can do
all kinds of things like that with the
same sort of logic that I'm about to
show you so anyway game intro we're just
going to have game intro it's going to
ask the question intro and it's going to
be for now we're going to set intro as
true and then we're going to have a
while loop that says while intro so as
long as the intro is true what do we
want to do so while intro we're going to
say for event in my game diet event dot
get empty parameters we're just going to
set we're just going to ask for a quit
event basically so we're going to say if
event dot type equals PI game dot quit
then we're going to run PI game dot quit
empty parameters and then just our
typical quit statement and that's it for
game intro um now what we'll do is we
come over here and we're going to say
game display fill and we're going to
fill it with white and then
and actually mode we actually want this
to you want it outside of the for loop
but you want it within the while loop so
game display dot fill whites and then
we're going to specify um the large text
basically we'll just take this right
here just to keep it short eventually it
might be wise to put the text up here at
the top and specify a few sizes of text
but for now we'll just copy and paste
this so we'll say games but I feel white
and then we'll say large text equals
that and then um we have basically
something very similar um to to this so
I guess we'll just rewrite it but um
let's see text objects now we'll just
copy and paste it that way we'll have to
rewrite it and actually we can keep the
blit as well he'll do copy that
come down here and we'll paste that and
now the text basically this was the
message that we wanted to say this is
like our intro screen so we're just
going to have it say a bit racy
um and then text center that's fine all
that other stuff is fine we will need
obviously at an update so we would say
like pi game dot display dot update and
then we would say o'clock dot tick and
then say tick for fifteen seconds so we
can save that and we can run that and
oops that's of course not going to run
because we never called game intro so we
can scroll down a little bit and now we
can just call like game underscore intro
empty programs save and run that and now
we get the game intro now of course we
have the game intro but we have no way
of like entering into the game so let's
go ahead and close this out and then we
can start talking about
the buttons so like I said before
there's absolutely no way - there's no
built-in functionality for buttons so it
should say there's no way but there's no
built-in thing in pygame like button and
do this you know like make a button but
we have all the tools that we need to
make a button so there's a few things I
haven't actually covered yet as far as
like the functionality that we would
need to know about in order to make a
button but we do know that a lot of
things exist so for example we can say
for event and pygame event get um we can
print the event so print event and we
can see I know I've showed it before but
we can see all the things that pygame
does grab so it grabs first of all the
mouse position we see that it knows
where our mouse is when it's on-screen
and we it also knows when we've clicked
it says you know button up and button
down kind of like a key up and key down
it knows when we clicked and it knows
where our mouse is so if that's the case
then all we need to do is make event
handling for where the mouse is if the
mouse goes over a button how do we make
a button well I just showed you guys and
we already knew how to make rectangles
so we can just make rectangles on the
screen and then we slap some text on
those rectangles and then now when we
put the mouse over the rectangle and
click on the rectangle it can have some
sort of button functionality so that's
what we're gonna be doing in the next
videos I'm gonna be showing you guys
we're going to draw the rectangle and
add you know maybe some hover to it or
something just to make the button feel
interactive and then click and all that
fun stuff and actually have it start the
game or leave the game or whatever so
definitely some exciting stuff there so
stay tuned for that as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time